مع استمرار الضربات التركيه على مناطق
وجود ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
يشير قائد تلك القوات الى ان حمايه
المنطقه هي وظيفه قوات النظام السوري وان
قواتهم تطلعوا الى التنسيق معها للتصدي
للهجمات التركيه تعيد هذا التصريحات الى
الواجهه الاسئله بشان شكل العلاقه بينما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والنظام
السوري وحتى الولايات المتحده الداعمه
الرئيسي لها بدايه فان المسلحين الاكراد
تشاركون حاليا الوجود مع قوات النظام
السوري في مناطق عديده في الحسكه
والقامشلي وحلاوه الرفعه بنسبه نفوذان
وسيطره متفاوته من منطقه الى اخرى هذا
التقاسم مسببه في اوقات سابقه اشتباكات
بينهما في الحسكه
بسبب تجاوز احدهما التفاهمات بشان كيفيه
اداره المنطقه الرسمي للنظام السوري عبر
تصريحات لرئيسه بشار الاسد وضع المسلحين
الاكراد وغيرهم من المدعومين من واشنطن في
خانه العماله والخيانه ومع ذلك فقد ساندت
قوات النظام السوري ترى من مره ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وان لم يحدث هذا
التدخل فرقا كما حدث في عفرين خلال عمليه
العسكريه التركيه عام 2018
اقدم من ذلك مع انطلاق الثوره السوريه
انسحبت قوات النظام السوري من مناطق في
شمال الشرقيه سوريا تاركه اداره المنطقه
المسلحين الاكراد وتولى هؤلاء في بعض
الاحيان قمع المظاهرات المناهضه لنظام
السوري والتي خرج فيها الاكراد والعرب
والشريان وكل مكونات المنطقه في المقابل
فانما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قاتلت
تنظيم الدوله بدعم من الولايات المتحده
لكن العمليات العسكريه التركيه السابقه
اشارت الى عدم رغبه واشنطن في دعم
المسلحين الاكراد في مواجهه الجيش التركي
وان كان الموقف الرسمي الامريكي يعلن
صراحه رفضات تلك العمليه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يشاركان تركيا تصنيفها
حزب العمال الكردستاني تنظيما الارهابيا
ومع ذلك فقد دعمته واشنطن وما زالت تدعم
المسلحين الافراد في سوريا على اختلاف
مسمياتهم والمصنفين من تركيا على انهم
امتداد ونسخه سوريه من حزب العمال
الكردستاني